David is inspiration yeah over the last
two years we've been looking at bunch of
different open houses but now have a
baby on the way so it's serious we
partnered with realtor.com to give you
guys a three-part series that's all
about our process of trying to find a
house I really do like our current place
we live in a rental house it was big
enough for the last three years but I
feel like we're just outgrowing it yeah
where are we gonna put the crib is a
diva and a closet it's like it's this
big and that takes up this much space
okay and we only have one bathroom so in
the mornings when we get ready we're
kind of like elevating each other and
it's a nice bike
the biggest thing I've ever purchased is
like a sweater that's not true did I buy
his clothes what is everything you want
in a house oh my gosh that is like the
question isn't it let's start with like
three pitches cuz we have one for the
nursery and then like a den and then
yesterday in office and I want every
bedroom to habits are backwards
oh my god we need four walk-in closets
is that right oh yeah a viewing area for
movies and things like that a separate
living room for talking right and
drinking whiskey we need to Russia's a
heated pool jacuzzi pool and then a tiny
dog pool house a tree house into the cat
we don't have a cat but we're gonna get
no I don't I can okay
kids even I think there should be two of
everything so then yes you and I never
have to share again mm-hmm that is what
marriage is about
hahaha let's search on realtor.com and
see if we can find that dream house home
sighs no max no lot size
no max RV boat parking because we want
to go inside rooms okay we want a
basement yes yes yes force facilities
didn't even think of that how about this
one this one's lovely oh it's beautiful
it's got a pool it's got a pool house
and only costs three point seven million
dollars okay maybe we'll just go for fun
but I have to pretend like we're really
fancy we are really fancy what is this I
don't know it's like a it's like a
secret tunnel there's a pool house
it's like an orange grove a grill it's
like a castle all right
why the fireplace is just like oh look
at these windows they're like bigger
than my head well most of it doesn't
bigger than here we like overlooking our
neighbors pizza fool it's a little
tennis court it's got not one but two
[Music]
the council is in session living room
outside look at this giant marble
countertop that's beautiful I mean it
like this is the largest kitchen island
I've ever seen wait what is this
that is a pot filler pot filler yeah you
turn it on and water comes out this
house is ridiculous wait is this a
second yeah my dishwasher oh so this is
your dishwasher you'll never free rinse
your dishes right and mine will always
be clean two ovens two dishwashers are
there two fridges yup this is a giant
porcelain fish with little scales it is
inedible I don't recommend eating look
at these doors it's just like good
morning
you know even a million-dollar house
there's a couple of things I would like
five or six I don't think I have enough
friends to have a party at this house
well at least we're almost to the point
of more stairs oh boy that's okay I just
like it you're paying this much much we
should come with an elevator Wow
I set a fireplace in every room and this
is like the guest bedroom yes yes it
does with a queen-size bed wow that's
fine China's a spoiled child yeah we're
having a baby
big bathroom for baby it's just a big
big room you could poop in a different
room okay
we go oh that master bedroom
[Music]
like it looks like a magazine cover even
the bedroom has another living room oh
my god I see like the biggest tub in the
world
bathtub chandelier I've only read about
no no no whoa uncle is here thank you
close close close close even the closet
has a chandelier this couples be a
vineyard you want to play some grapes
out here yeah do what we call our wine
label boomers wine Chardin ed full
folder too low bummer love
maybe we can't afford everything that we
want so we're gonna have to make some
compromises well we'll have to you know
cut down the bathrooms in the bedrooms
maybe a pool might be too much we can do
this I think maybe we just need help
yeah you're right yeah yeah we have no
idea ordinary did you steal one of my
lemons why are there haunted houses
[Music]
dog can't use the real poll he can but
this is for him and his friends when the
chili got it